So far in this lesson,
when two repositories have gotten out
of sync, it's always been a matter of
one repository having commits that
the other doesn't, like in this case.
What if both repositories have new
commits reachable from the same branch?
What do you think would happen if
you pulled or pushed in this case?
When you pulled earlier in the lesson,
your local repository didn't have any
commits that the remote was missing, so
pulling set your state to
the be the same as the remote.
But if that happened in this case,
we would be losing this commit.
So, what really happens
when you pull a branch?
What you want is a combined
version of both of these branches.
Does this sound familiar?
What you really want to do is merge the
local and remote versions of the branch.
We'll get into the details of
how that works soon once you
actually have some changes in
both repositories to incorporate.
For personal projects, this would only
happen in practice if you are working
from multiple different machines or
made some edits directly on GitHub and
others locally.
The more common reason for
an issue like this to come up is when
you're collaborating with others.
Caroline and
I will demonstrate collaboration, but
unfortunately, we don't have the time to
directly collaborate with each of you.
You'll follow along with Caroline's
side of the collaboration.
And when I make changes, you'll run
some code that we wrote to make it
look like I've made the same
changes in your repository.
We'll give instructions on how
to do this when the time comes.
First, you'll make a quick change
to one of the recipes locally.
After this video, you'll see
some instructions for doing so.